[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
we want to see
blackhead coaches in the nfl and coaches
of
people of color
and eventually gender roger goodell
speaks out for the first time since the
nfl is sued for discrimination and eight
years after a deadly shooting opening
statements will soon be presented in the
trial of an ex-police captain plus sarah
palin takes the stand as she sues the
new york times for defamation the latest
from the federal courtroom but first the
death of amir loch hear from the 22 year
old's mother just one week after his
death i sometimes have to put my hand
across my chest to
make sure my heart is still leading
because i never felt
such a hollow
feeling lawn crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the mother of a man shot and
killed by minneapolis police as they
served a no-knock warrant wants answers
and justice this as newly released
search warrants layout why officers ask
for a no knock warrant law on crime's
angel levy is here with the story
brian when minneapolis police barged
into that apartment back on february 2nd
they were actually looking for evidence
related to a murder in which locke's
seventeen-year-old cousin
mechai speed was a suspect now speed is
now charged with murdering a man in
saint paul that man's name is otis elder
saint paul of course is a sister city to
minneapolis now body camera video showed
that raid and it showed the officers in
the apartment and locked sleeping on a
couch with a gun he legally owned
officers fired killing locke who was
holding that gun
locke was sleeping in the apartment of
his older cousin's girlfriend not the
apartment of speed's mother they were
also searching that apartment as well an
application for the warrant says that
officers wanted a no-knock warrant to
quote prevent the loss
destruction or removal of the objects of
the search it goes on to say that speed
and another suspect have a history of
violent crimes that is no consolation
though to amir lock's mother karen
i want people wells know that
he was a bright light
he had a beautiful spirit
he was very respectful
um we raised him on morals and values
he loved me he loved his father he loved
all of his siblings
um
and anytime he came in contact with
somebody and showed you his smile they
automatically like gravitated towards
them i want them to ban the no knock
warrant across the united states
and i also want
everybody that was involved in the
execution of my son
one two two twenty two i want everybody
brought to justice this was obviously
very over broad even from the standpoint
of issuing the warrants they went into
four different departments
um we you know we've now learned from
the affidavits that have been released
so you know aside from executing the
type of warrant that never should have
been executed it was overbroad you know
to begin with based on our initial
review
now karen wells had a press conference
in saint paul minnesota with briana
taylor's mother calling for a ban on no
knock warrants taylor you'll recall was
killed in 2020 in louisville kentucky as
police executed a no knock warrant on
her apartment mecha speed is currently
charged with second degree murder and
prosecutors will ask that he be tried as
an adult meanwhile the minnesota
attorney general is investigating the
shooting of amir lock brian
thanks angela joining us today is civil
rights attorney sue ann robinson and
terry austin suan all eyes seem to be on
this no knock warrant what does it help
tell us about lock's death
i think the warrant shows us
that a warrant a no knock warrant is
basically almost like a license to kill
and it's something that has to be very
very
if it's going to be used it has to be
done with precision and what's shown in
the document is there is a lack of
precision there is a lot of
evidence in there discussing them
surveilling the suspects and how they
were following the suspects and
following them to different areas but
there's no indication that they actually
surveilled the suspects that they were
looking for on the night they executed
the warrant to make sure that they were
in the place that they were executing a
no knock warrant and that's why you know
there's an issue with it i think the
problem really is that we have to really
look at these no knock warrants as
licenses to kill because essentially
that is exactly what could happen if you
burst into a house in the middle of the
night without announcing yourself you
could end up killing someone and when
you are giving when a judge or when an
investigator a detective a police
officer is applying for something like
that it has to be done with higher
scrutiny and higher precision and it's
just not there in this case absolutely
now terry after hearing locke's family
speak do you think there will be major
changes in minnesota to know knock
warrants
well i sure hope so brian the family was
very impactful they said the one thing
they want is for the police officers
involved they want them fired and they
want them prosecuted and then as far as
the no knock warrants concerned yes
suanne is right there needs to be
changes we have to limit it to
situations perhaps like when there are
hostages because otherwise we see these
types of issues being raised the fact
that people are getting killed because
they are shocked when someone barges in
especially in places where they have uh
license to carry guns in their home and
karen wells mentioned one of the
officers being brought to justice what
would she like to be done
well she wants to see charges filed not
only against that police officer
who fired the fatal shot but also the
shots rather but also the other police
officers involved in this raid she wants
to see
keith ellison's office bring those
charges you'll recall that minnesota
attorney general keith ellison of course
prosecuted derek chovin he filed charges
against the other three officers in
george floyd's death and he put out a
statement last week saying amir lock's
life mattered i don't know if that
foreshadows anything but his office is
looking into this yeah of course we'll
keep eyes on this case as it develops to
see if there are any charges whether it
be a civil rights case charge at large
or to those specific officers thank you
everyone in a federal court a judge
rules there is quote overwhelming
evidence of guilt in michael avenatti's
nike case meaning the disgraced lawyer
will not receive a new trial the ruling
comes just one week after avenatti's
latest federal conviction for stealing
some 300 thousand dollars from former
client and adult film actress stormy
daniels last summer a u.s district judge
sentenced avenatti to two and a half
years in prison for what he calls an
outrageous scheme to extort up to 25
million dollars from nike on monday of
this week avenatti reported to federal
authorities he is currently being held
at the metropolitan detention center in
los angeles
still ahead on law and crime daily jury
selection winds down in the case of a
former police officer on trial for
murder but first one time alaska
governor sarah palin takes the stand in
federal court the latest developments in
the new york times defamation lawsuit
next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
sarah palin takes the stand in a
defamation lawsuit against the new york
times in her testimony palin referred to
herself as david and the new york times
as goliath based on a 2017 story she
says defamed her palin filed suit
against the new york the newspaper and a
former editorial page editor for a story
that linked a 2011 mass shooting in
arizona to her political activities the
former vice presidential nominee alleges
the article said her political
advertisement took aim at a victim of
the shooting an arizona representative
at the time the time says the article
was corrected within a day palin
testified this week saying death threats
to she and her family ramped up after
the article on cross-examination she
told jurors quote i can't specifically
give you any name of someone who told me
that they didn't want me to help them
when asked about the effects of this
article the new york times has not lost
a defamation lawsuit in more than 50
years
back to break down palin's lawsuit as
civil rights attorney suanne robinson
and terry austin terry in a defamation
case involving a public figure like
sarah palin she has to show actual
malice by the new york times do you see
any here
actually brian i do not see actual
malice it was defined in a supreme court
case and you probably remember this case
new york times v sullivan and where they
defined it was they're saying it has to
be reckless disregard or the person who
makes the statement has to know that it
was false and we don't have those facts
here not only that brian but there was a
retraction and a correction immediately
afterwards within a day so i don't think
she's going to be able to prove that the
new york times acted with actual malice
all right so i'm reading law and crimes
adam classfeld's tweets he's there in
the court live tweeting and palin says
this isn't about losing income and she
can't identify who shied away from her
after his publication so where are the
damages
it's i don't see the damages and i think
that's the problem that's part of the
problem with the case i mean aside from
the fact that it's hard for her to
demonstrate what was in the new york
times editor's mind which is what would
be required because she was a public
figure she would also have to
demonstrate damages she would have to
say hey i had this contract with this
media company and after this was
published they
the contract disappeared or i lost these
speaking opportunities based on what was
published and that those are my damages
i just don't see any damages here yeah
maybe that 50-plus year winning streak
by the new york time may be extended
unless we can see more from sarah palin
this case but of course we'll give you
updates as the case continues
this week on brian ross investigates an
epidemic sweeping the nation chief
investigative reporter brian ross joins
us now with a look ahead at this week's
episode
thanks brian this week on brian ross
investigates an american scourge not
cloven 19 but the crisis with opiates
that's claimed tens of thousands of
lives and no group in our country has
been harder hit than native americans
most of us are living you know um at
moderate to low income levels you know
we have lots of struggling families and
so we're susceptible to
the folks getting caught up in the
opiates so it causes a lot of disruption
to our families
they become dysfunctional they become
dependent
we have some challenges somewhat some
will uh end up in other kinds of crime
and and it's also spiritually for us and
culturally if i should say it that way
um it's a it's it's challenging for us
because we consider ourselves strong
people and we consider ourselves
independent people and then when you
see some of your people um start
becoming dependent on opiates and and
other substance abuses
then it becomes a very uh
disruptive to
the harmony of our community that's
coming up this week on brian ross
investigates on the law and crime trial
network
you can catch brian ross investigates
tuesdays and thursdays at 5 30 p.m
eastern time here on lawn crime network
coming up on law and crime daily nfl
commissioner roger goodell speaks out on
diversity in the wake of a
discrimination lawsuit against the
league plus opening statements will soon
be presented in the case of curtis
reeves still ahead what's expected in
the case that's taken years to go to
trial
[Music]
welcome back after taking a day off
wednesday a full 12-person jury was
selected on thursday in a florida
courtroom for the trial of accused
serial killer robert hayes hayes is
accused of killing three women and
dumping their bodies in the daytona
beach area between november 2005 and
february 2006. authorities allege
laquita gunther julie green and iwana
payton were sex workers haze targeted
hayes later moved to west palm beach
where he's accused in another woman's
2016 murder it was after that alleged
murder when authorities linked hayes to
the three shooting deaths in daytona
beach jury selection consisted of
attorneys asking potential jurors
questions in groups including asking if
they could handle deciding this case as
prosecutors are seeking the death
penalty opening statements are expected
to begin friday
and jury selection stretched into a
fourth day in florida as a former police
captain prepares to face trial eight
years after he allegedly shot and killed
a man in a movie theater former officer
curtis reeves is charged with
second-degree murder in the shooting
death of chad olson rees and olson were
attending a showing of the movie lone
survivor in 2014 when the two got into
an argument over olson texting during
the previews reeves claims olson was
coming at him and said he feared for his
life he says he then shot olson in
self-defense
back in 2017 reeves argued his case in a
stand your ground hearing but a judge
ruled against him on thursday attorneys
began with a pool of 52 potential jurors
working to whittle it down to a group of
10 questioning focus on potential jurors
feeling on carrying weapons while a
traditional jury is made up of 12 people
reeves jury will be made up of six
panelists and four alternates 79 year
old reeves faces a possible life
sentence if convicted opening statements
are expected to start on friday
all right so we've got co-host terry
austin back with us to discuss the
murder in the movie theater terry what
do you think the prosecution's strongest
argument is in this case
you know what based on all the reports
i've heard so far and what the attorneys
have been saying during the voir dire i
think the prosecution has a very strong
argument reeves is being charged with
second-degree murder which means that he
had a depraved mind that he had no
regard for human life and frankly the
fact that he shot someone to death
because they threw popcorn at him and
because they were using a cell phone in
my mind means that he was disregarding
life and he was also charged with
aggravated battery and all you have to
do in florida there is to show that he
was actually using a deadly weapon and
we know he was using a deadly weapon so
i think the prosecution has a very good
case here brian i mean i i would imagine
so especially because reeves lost his
stand your ground hearing doesn't that
mean he legally should have retreated
before using deadly force against olson
absolutely that was a big loss for him
under florida law you have the fact that
you have self-defense but if you see
imminent threat of death or if you see
imminent threat of danger to your body
then of course you can use self-defense
but you do have that duty to retreat
unless there's the castle document
meaning that you are in your own home or
if you can show that you can stand your
ground you don't have that duty to
retreat but here he lost that argument
so i would say he would have to show he
really was an imminent threat of death
or bodily harm and i think he should
have retreated here obviously yeah it's
gonna be interesting how that plays out
with his status of being a former
captain does it help or hurt him you're
gonna have to tune into law and crime
network for capital gable coverage to
see how that plays out when we come back
hear from nfl commissioner roger goodell
on allegations of racism and
discrimination in the league why he says
the nfl fell short in promoting
diversity among its employees
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
we're hearing from the nfl commissioner
roger goodell for the first time since
the league was slammed with a diversity
lawsuit as co-host darry allison
explains that can mean major changes for
the nfl policies
brian in a press conference this week
commissioner roger goodell said the
league will soon reevaluate current
practices meaning there could be updates
on even removal of the so-called rooney
rule this comes after former miami
dolphins head coach brian flores filed a
lawsuit against the nfl and multiple
teams flores who is black alleges he was
only interviewed for a head coaching job
with the new york giants to fulfill the
rooney rule which requires minority
candidates to be interviewed for head
coaching positions court documents show
text messages sent from patriots head
coach bill belichick to flores
congratulating him on the giant's head
coaching job before he was even
interviewed belichick later apologized
saying he meant to text brian dayball a
white man who was ultimately offered the
position
last week commissioner goodall released
a memo saying the league's efforts to
promote diversity when hiring head
coaches have been unacceptable on
wednesday he doubled down on that saying
that racism and discrimination will not
be tolerated and that changes need to be
made
it's really more important to talk about
what coach flores was talking about and
other coaches have talked about with
respect to what really is happening in
the hiring process what's good what's
bad what's not leading us to the results
that we expect to have
we have spent an extraordinary amount of
time with our committees particularly
our diversity equity and inclusion
committee but also with our membership
in general to sort of talk about the
process
uh i think we made a tremendous amount a
lot of progress in a lot of areas
but not at the head coach
and that is something that uh is
something we really have focused on
to try to get the kind of results that
we would expect and we fell short of
that by a long shot
commissioner goodall said the league
will hire outside experts in diversity
equity and inclusion to review the
league's practices brian
thanks terry samantha flores fight seems
similar to what you do as a civil rights
attorney so how would you evaluate
flores claim against the nfl
i think you know men lie women lie
numbers don't if over 55 percent of the
nfl players are black and less than one
percent of the head coaches are black
those are the numbers with civil rights
cases a lot of times it's on the pla
it's the plaintiff's burden to prove
the discrimination and i think in brian
flora's case he has a smoking gun in
that combined with the rooney rule with
which requires a diverse applicant to be
identified and interviewed he has that
text where
the other candidate the white candidate
is already being congratulated before he
even has the opportunity to be
interviewed so that's something in a
civil rights case you rarely get it's a
smoking gun into um the mindset of the
nfl like hey these guys are just trying
to move around the rules to look like
they're adhering to diversity but in
actuality this is what's really
happening so flores has a very strong
case with that text message as a smoking
gun for sure all right and i'm waiting
to see belichick deposed after that text
message that's that's gonna be the
exciting part terry as the former chief
diversity officer of a fortune 500
company uh what changes do you think the
nfl should implement to make progress
listen there's so much they could do and
commissioner goodell should not have
waited until a class action has been
filed he needed to have implemented
changes long ago you could see that the
rooney rule was not working so you have
to do more and you have to make cultural
changes it starts at the top put your
money where your mouth is you have to
interview candidates look for them get
candidates who are qualified from
diverse backgrounds they're failing to
do that right now they're falling back
on old habits and not really pushing
forward so so much to do yeah we'll see
as this lawsuit progresses thank you
both and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you